Ich möchte Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Melanie Schleving.
Schleving.
Okay.
Ich buste mir Ihren Namen.
Melanie wie M, E, L, A, N, I, Ida, E.
Und Ihren Nachname?
Wie schule Sie S, G, H, L, E, V, William, W, I, Ida und Doppel-A.
Schleving.
I, I, N, G, G, Schleving.
Okay.
Vielen Dank Frau Schleving.
Wie heiß sind Sie?
Ich bin 39 Jahre alt.
Sie sind sehr jung.
Und Sie sind sehr jung.
Und wann sind Sie denn nahe geworden?
Am 14. Februar 1986.
1986.
Wissen Sie aktuell, wie groß Sie sind und wie viel Sie wiegen?
Ja, 1,74 m.
Und ich wiege 68 kg.
68 kg.
Okay.
Frau Schleving.
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was für Becheverter haben Sie?
Ja, ich habe ungefähr vor 2 Stunden hat das begonnen.
Da habe ich ganz akuten Schmerz gehabt.
Im Brustkorbbereich hinten, hinten in der Brust.
Auf der Rückseite sozusagen, am Schulterblatt.
Ganz akut, hat das sehr stark weh.
Okay.
Ich habe noch einen Schmerz.
6 bis 7.
Frau Schleving.
Haben Sie Atomnot dabei?
Ja, ich habe da sehr starke Luftnot dabei gehabt.
Ich habe immer noch Luftnot.
Und bin sehr aufgeregt.
Okay.
Haben Sie früher ähnliche Warnung?
Noch habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Okay.
Leiden Sie an chronische Herzkrankheit,
Ruhdhochdruck oder Zuckerkrankheit?
Nein, so etwas habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Sie haben sehr starke Schmerzen.
Und ich trage diese Schmerzen auf den Schulterblatt.
Rechts Seite?
Nein, mehr unten.
Mehr so tiefer.
Etwas tiefer ist das.
Also da unten am Schulterblatt, am unteren Bereich des Schulterblattes.
Schulterblatt.
Okay.
Ja, Frau Schleving, ich muss unsere Gespräche unterbrechen.
Ich denke, es ist eine akute Probleme.
Ich muss bei Ihnen eine EKG geschrieben.
Dann werde ich bei Ihnen einen Venösezugang anlegen.
Und Ihre Metallparameter messen.
Darüber hinaus werde ich die Laborparameter,
Herzentzüge, anlassen.
Okay.
Ich habe auch Ihren Blutgas überpüft.
Und ich gebe Ihnen Sauerstoff.
Bitte schön.
Okay.
Gut, das können wir so machen.
Aber ich möchte eine Frage.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen aushalten bis unsere Gespräche beendet ist?
Ja, das kann ich noch.
Ja, das kann ich.
Okay.
Ich beide nicht.
Frau Schleving, Könnten Sie bitte diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind diese Schmerzen dummbrennende oder ziehen die Schmerzen?
Also, der Schmerz wird etwas stärker, wenn ich einatme, wenn ich Luft hole.
Dann habe ich den Eindruck, der Schmerz wird stärker.
Und der Schmerz ist mehr, ja, es ist mehr so ein dumpfer Schmerz.
Aber er kam ganz plötzlich.
Okay.
Vor zwei Stunden passiert, was machen Sie, Könnten Sie bitte beschreiben?
Was machen Sie damals vor zwei Stunden?
Vor zwei Stunden habe ich am Frühstückstisch gesessen und habe eine Tasse Kaffee getrunken
und ein Stück Toastbrot gegessen.
Es war ganz normal.
Ich habe mich ganz normal gefühlt.
Ich meine, ich habe wegen Akustik ein bisschen unterbrechen nicht gehört.
Ich habe eine Tasse Kaffee trinken und Brotzen gegessen.
Ich habe eine Scheibe Toast gegessen und Kaffee getrunken.
Ich habe mich nicht angestrengt oder so.
Hören Sie mich noch?
Ja, ich höre.
Alles klar.
Sie haben normales Kaffee getrunken.
Ja.
Sie haben kein Stress oder...
Da war alles gut.
Sie haben starke Husten oder Obstipationen oder Verstoffungen.
Nein, hatte ich nicht.
Sie haben Trauma oder Verlösungen.
Ich bin ja relativ sportlich.
Ich laufe regelmäßig.
Vor einer Woche bin ich beim Joggen mit dem linken Fuß umgeknickt.
Mit dem linken Bein und mit dem Fuß.
Da wurde das Fußgelenk unten ganz dick.
Es ist inzwischen auch ziemlich blau verfärbt.
Ich habe es gekühlt und habe mit Eis behandelt.
Ich habe es hochgelegt und Bandage gemacht.
Es wird jetzt ganz langsam besser.
Aber ich kann noch nicht gut auftreten.
Herr Stee, Frau Schläbing, Sie haben gut gemacht.
Bei uns gekommen, Fuß umgeknitten.
Hausarzt besucht oder Ortepeidin besucht?
Ich habe bisher noch keinen Arzt aufgesucht.
Wenn es nicht besser wird, wollte ich zum Arzt gehen.
Aber ich habe es bisher noch nicht gemacht.
Ich verstehe.
Frau Schläbing, sind Sie unmächtig geworden?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Etwas übel ist mir.
Aber keine Erbrochen.
Nein, ich habe nicht Erbrochen.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein.
Haben Sie Husten und Blut im Blut?
Ich habe etwas Hustenreiz, aber kein Blut.
Ich habe es nicht bemerkt.
Gibt es Arzt-Husch?
Nein.
Wie fühlen Sie sich gerade nach Sauerstoff?
Es geht mir etwas besser.
Ich habe aber den Eindruck, mein Herz schlägt jetzt ziemlich schnell.
Das war aber jetzt schon, als die Schmerzen anfing.
Mein Herz schlägt ziemlich schnell.
Ich habe ihren Lavoparameter geschickt.
Die mehrere und die andere Blut-Gerünung werden mir anschauen.
Ich denke, Sie haben lungengefasene Probleme.
Deswegen werde ich bei Ihnen eine Blutverlünung im Spitzen.
Und Frau Schläbing, wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Mein Appetit ist normalerweise gut.
Aber jetzt, als ich die Schmerzen habe und die Luftnot habe,
habe ich keinen Hunger.
Sonst kann ich gut essen.
Sind Sie in letzter Zeit abgenommen?
Nein, ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten.
Ihr musst stabil sein.
Sind Sie im Bein Schwellungen bemerkt?
Ja, das linke Bein ist am Unterschenkel geschwollt.
Und am Knöchel ist es auch blau.
Das ist ein Bluterguss.
Ach, dann diese Umfalt, oder?
Ja.
Schwellungen und Schmerzen.
Gibt es auch Schmerzen bei dieser Lokalisation?
Ja, die Stelle, wo es blau ist, ist noch druckschmerzhaft.
Da ist es empfindlich.
Ja, druckschmerz.
Ja, Frau Schläbing, ich möchte einige Fragen noch stellen.
Sie haben heute plötsch Brustschmerzen hinter Brust
und tiefer Schulter und parallel während Atmung.
Reisfusten, aber kein Fieber, oder?
Kein Fieber.
Kein Nachschweiß oder Schulterfrust?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Aber ein bisschen Übelkeit, keine Albrechen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen Stugan?
Nein, habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Alles in Ordnung, Wasserlassen.
Ich habe gefragt, aber leider haben Sie keine Altezucker,
keine Bluthochdruck.
Ja, aber ich habe Asthma.
Asthma Brustschmerzen, seit wann?
Seit der Kindheit.
Da nehme ich auch zwei verschiedene Sprays ein.
Ich habe auch Neurodermitis.
Seit wann?
Ja, auch so, seit der Kindheit.
Was ist diese Krankheit?
Sag es mir bitte, welche Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Ich würde gegen das Asthma nehmen, das Mittel heißt Viani.
V-I-A-N-I, das sind so Kapseln.
Die muss ich in einen Apparat reinstecken und drauf drücken.
Da kommt ein Nebel, ein Staub.
Wie oft nehmen Sie?
Zwei Mal am Tag.
Sonst nehmen ich noch Salbutamol.
Das nehme ich meistens vor dem Sport.
Eine Viertelstunde vor dem Joggen.
Sonst nehmen Sie nicht.
Sonst nehme ich das Salbutamol nicht.
Und gegen Neurodermitis, benutzen Sie Creme, Salbe?
Manchmal, manchmal Creme.
Manchmal, wenn die Neurodermitis sehr stark ist,
dann muss ich auch manchmal eine Creme mit Cortison nehmen.
Da gehe ich zum Hautarzt.
Der Hautarzt verschreibt mir das.
Okay, kannst du dir.
Ich habe noch eine Schilddrösenvergrößerung.
Ich habe seit der Jugend
auf der linken Seite der Schilddröse zwei Knoten.
Die werden auch regelmäßig kontrolliert.
Die Schilddröse ist jetzt langsam kleiner geworden,
weil ich auch ein Medikament einnehme.
Nehmen Sie Eutroxin?
Ich nehme Eutyrox.
Ja, für diese Knotenkleiner.
Ja, damit die Schilddröse kleiner wird.
Die Knoten sind immer noch da.
Die haben sich nicht verändert.
Ich nehme 75.
75? Einmal.
Einmal morgens, ja.
Sonst noch andere Medikamente, Krankheit?
Ich nehme noch die Pille ein.
Okay, wegen Terschütto?
Ja.
Seit wann benutzen Sie Pille?
Das ist schon einige Jahre.
Die Rate haben immer gewechselt.
Wann war Ihre Listeperiode für Erschliung?
Vor zwei Wochen.
Ist es möglich, dass Sie gerade nicht gewandt sind?
Das glaube ich nicht.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Ich habe einen Kind, neun Jahre alt.
Die Tochter ist gesund.
Gesund.
Wo sind Sie mit Ihrer Familie zusammen?
Was macht Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Architektin.
Haben Sie das bei der Arbeit?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ich bin selbstständiger Architektin.
Nein, das bin ich.
Brav.
Ich habe immer Stress.
Viele Leute sagen immer, ich habe Stress.
Aber ich glaube, nein, mir gefällt das.
Ja, Sie sind nicht stark gebraucht.
Wurden Sie sich schon einmal operiert?
Als Kind mit elf Jahren,
ich war elf Jahre am Blinder.
Vor zwölf Jahren war das.
Ich hatte beim Radfahren einen Sturz.
Ich hatte mir das linke Schienenbein gebrochen.
Das musste operiert werden.
Gebrochen.
Aber keine Beschwerden.
Ist das eine Plenar-Planning?
Ja, das ist eine Plenar-Planning.
Ist das eine Platin Oster-Santis?
Ja, das war eine Platin.
Ja, die gemacht wurde.
Wann war das?
Vor zwölf Jahren.
Sonst noch eine Operation? Nein.
Verliebt diese OP gut?
Ja, die waren alle in Ordnung.
Okay, außer diese Krankheit oder Problems,
die Situation, waren Sie in Krankenhausstationäre?
Nur bei der Geburt meiner Tochter.
Aha, ja.
Sind Sie normal gebohrt?
Ja, kein Kaiserschnitt.
Sind Sie allergisch gegen das?
Wie bitte?
Nein, ich bin nicht bekannt.
Und vertragst du alles?
Ja, ich muss etwas aufpassen bei der Neurodermitis.
Ich esse sowieso wenig Fleisch.
Das merke ich, wenn ich etwas mehr Fleisch esse,
da reagiert die Haut manchmal stärker.
Okay, wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Indem die Neurodermitis schlimmer wird.
Okay, schlimmer.
Hat Arschlag, Yukreis?
Ja, ja, das ist extrem schlimmer.
Schlimmer.
Haben Sie keine Medikamentealergie?
Nein, ich bin nicht bekannt.
Frau Schläbing, rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Manchmal abends zum Abendessen ein kleines Glas Wein.
Das ist aber wirklich nur ein Achtel.
Aber nicht jeden Abend.
Ein kleines Glas.
Meinen Sie 100 ml?
Ein Achtel.
Es gibt ja eine halbe Liter, ein viertel Liter
und ein Achtel Liter.
125, ja, ein Achtel.
Vielen Dank.
Das ist ja wichtig, wie vor dem Mass.
Und vielen Dank.
Leben Ihre Alten noch, Frau Schläbing?
Ja, mein Vater ist 72 Jahre alt.
Der hat hohen Blutdruck.
Und der hat Alterszucker.
Und sonst?
Ja, er ist 71 Jahre alt.
Er hat auch Asthma und Neurodermitis.
Und sie hatte 2 Mal eine Beinwenentrombose.
Oh, ist sehr leid.
Und aktuell ist sie gesund?
Ja, bis auf Asthma und Neurodermitis ist sie gesund.
Und haben Sie die Schwester?
Ja, ich habe noch einen Bruder.
Der ist 39 Jahre alt.
Der hat auch Asthma.
Besuchen Sie regelmäßig Ihren Frauenarzt?
Ja, ich gehe regelmäßig zur Frauenärztin.
Einmal im Jahr.
Und letzte Kontrolle war im Februar.
Und das war alles gut.
Sind Sie in der letzten Zeit?
Ja, ich bin in der letzten Zeit.
Ich habe noch einen Bruder.
Und das ist gut.
Sind Sie vorständig geimpft gegen aktuelle Krankheiten?
Ja, das überprüft meine Hausärztin immer.
Sie sagte mir jetzt im Winter,
ich bin zurzeit gut ausreichend geimpft.
Super.
Und dreifeln Sie sich regelmäßig?
Ja, dreimal in der Woche jogge ich.
Jeweils eine Stunde.
Aber in der letzten Woche eben nicht.
Weil ich da nicht laufen konnte.
Und waren Sie in den letzten Seid in Ausland?
Ich war in Österreich im Winter zum Skifahren.
Und am Ereignis Januar?
Ja, das war im Februar.
Ich war zehn Tage zum Skifahren.
Aber sonst war ich in den letzten Monaten nicht im Ausland.
Alles war in Ordnung.
Ihr Blub war sehr gut.
Keine Entzündung, kein Problem.
Nein?
Wie fühlen Sie sich gerade?
Mit dem Sauerstoff geht es mir etwas besser.
Ich hoffe, dass es mir bald richtig gut geht.
Ja, machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Wir werden alles machen, um Sie wieder gesund zu sein.
Gut.
Ich lebe, ich bin fertig.
Wärsten Sie etwas wie zu viel?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Danke, dann haben Sie jetzt etwas Zeit,
umzuschreiben.
Sie wissen ja schon alles.
Und denken Sie an die Fachbegriffe.
Kollegen und Kolleginnen, die jetzt zugehört oder zugesehen
schaut haben, die haben vielleicht noch eine Frage oder Fragen.
Die können wir jetzt beantworten.
Oder vielleicht ist alles klar.
Die Diagnose ist schon gestellt.
Sie haben ja auch die Fragen gut gestellt.
Und ausreichend gestellt.
Niemand hat sonst eine Frage.
Noch mal zur Lokalisation der Schmerzen.
Die Patientin berichtet,
dass die Schmerzen plötzlich auftraten.
Hinten am Brustkorb.
Also auf der Rückseite eher, nicht vorne.
Sondern hinten.
Und da unten sah, wo das Schulterblatt,
der untere Teil des Schulterblattes ist.
Da in der Gegend.
Da ist der Hauptschmerz.
Und da war auch der starke Schmerz gerade zu Anfang.
Wenn Sie sagen, ich weiß, ich kann das jetzt machen,
schon die Vorstellung beim Oberarzt,
dann können wir das auch jetzt schon beginnen.
Hallo, schönen guten Tag.
Herr Oberarzt, ich habe eine neue Patientin,
die ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Es geht um Frau Melianich Leving.
Sie ist 39 Jahre alt.
Seitlich, örtlich und persönlich gut orientiert.
Aber in
Schmerz bedingte reduzierte
allgemeine Zustände und normale Ernährung.
Frau Leving starte sich bei uns
seit 2 Stunden,
bei uns vor und seit 2 Stunden
plötzlich bestehende,
zunehmende, retroschthernalisch
Schmerzen, besonders
unterteilskapula,
unterteilskapula, ja.
Darüber hinaus klagte sie über
inspiratoa, inspiratoa
Schmerzen.
Die Schmerz interstetliche bei 6-7
von 10
auf der Schmerz-Kalat.
Die Schmerz
würden
sein dumpfer, dumpf,
stärker und dumpf.
Ich möchte einmal kurz unterbrechen.
Danke.
Sie haben gesagt,
die Patientin klagt seit 2 Stunden
über einen plötzlich aufgetretenen
retroschthernalen Schmerz.
Retroschthernal ist ja direkt hinter dem Brustbein.
Sternum.
Sie haben Brustkop gesagt.
Sagen Sie lieber über einen
rechtstorakalen Schmerz.
Mehr Dorsal.
Das ist ja der Schmerz-Dorsal.
Das könnte retroschthernal sein,
hinter dem Brustbein.
Dieser Schmerz ist aber hinten im Bereich
der Skapula, der Skapula-Region, des unteren
Skapula-Winkels. Also sagen wir ruhig einen
rechtsdorsalen Schmerz im
Torakal. Der hat Torakal, das ist der Brustkopf.
Und zwar Dorsal ist der Schmerz, nicht ventral.
Aber ansonsten
fahren Sie fort.
Okay.
Ja, nicht retroschthernal. Denken Sie,
retroschthernal ist ja direkt hinter dem Brustbein.
Ja, ja.
Malen Sie mal kurz auf.
Der Schmerz ist aber hier hinten.
Ja, Sie haben gezeigt.
Skapula-Inferior.
Ja.
Darüber hinaus
erinnern
die Patienten, dass
vor einem Woche nach
einem Joggen
mit ihrem Fuß eine
Subination Trauma
gehabt, ihren linkseitigen Fuß
mit einer
Subination Trauma gehabt.
Aber sie habe keine
arztische
sie habe keine ihren Hausarzt besucht.
Nur etwas konservativ
selber gemacht.
Und mit Eis gekühlt.
Aussehnden
haben Sie gerade auch diese linkseitige Fuß
Ödem
Hematoma und Schmerzen
habe.
Ich sage es noch mal, ich sage es wieder, hol es noch mal.
Die Patientin berichtet,
dass sie vor einer Woche beim Joggen
eine Distortion,
eine Subination Trauma haben Sie ja richtig gesagt.
Ein Subination Trauma
im linken Sprunggelenk erlitten hat.
Sie ist also umgeknickt, so nennen wir das.
Und sie hat daraufhin
in selbst behandelt
mit Hochlagerung, Kühlung
und Salbenverbänden.
Und es hat sich jetzt in den letzten Tagen
wohl eine Hematomverfärbung
der Fußbleulich Livide verfärbt.
Und es besteht eine Schwellung
und diese Schwellung besteht wohl auch
im Bereich des distalen Unterschenkels.
Das ist noch ganz wichtig.
Gut.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Umgeknickt bedeutet Distortion?
Ja, Distortion.
Die Subination, es klingt außen um,
am Außenband
und nicht zu den Innen.
Nach Innen umkickt selten.
Wenn der Fuß außen umkickt,
ist es ein Subination Trauma.
Dargen Sie ruhig,
sie hat sich eine Distortion,
eine Verletzung zum Zogen.
Ja.
Die zweite Renne klagte sie über.
Reise husten.
Und
keine die andere.
Hatte die Patientin einen schnellen Puls?
Ja, ja, sie hat gesagt.
Takikardi.
Atemnot.
Ich habe sofort unterbrechen, Ihrem Glutgasanalyst überprüft, die die mehrere Troponinverten ich habe veranlasst.
Okay, hat die Patientinnen Auffälligkeiten beim Blutdruck oder beim SBO2?
Ja, sie hat keine Bluthochdruck, aber Asthma Brunschale.
Aber jetzt der Blutdruck bei dem Vitalparametern?
Ja, sie hat ein bisschen hoch Glutdruck, die Blutdruckwert ist hoch und Blutgasanalyst ist ein bisschen problematisch.
Deswegen muss ich Blutgasauerstoff geben.
Wie hat die Patientin auf den Sauerstoff reagiert?
Ja, sie hat ja gut reagiert.
Also positiv reagiert?
Ja, sie hat ja positiv reagiert.
Fahren Sie bitte fort.
Ja, die Frage nach Pregsi, Vertigo und Hemoptysie wurden vernein.
Die vegetative Anemnes ist unauffällig.
Bis auf, bis auf, ist unauffällig.
Die Patientin klart über etwas nausea, aber keine Medizin.
Hat die Patientin chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, sie hat chronische Erkrankungen seit Kindheit,
sie hat eine ganze Zeit mit der Patientin, die sie hat.
Aber ich habe sie schon seit 20 Jahren mit der Patientin.
Wie?
Und sie leiden an Neurodermitis seit langem, dagegen sie achten auf weniger Fleisch essen.
Weil wenn sie zu viel Essen gegessen haben, die Dermatitis extrem verschlimmert.
Ja.
Gibt es andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, seit Jugend hat sie Probleme mit der Vergöntung von Krumpen oder Strom und Knoten.
Ja, Strom.
Promanodose.
Genau, Strom-Anodose.
Sehr gut.
Wie viele Knoten hat sie?
Zwei.
Knoten links Seite.
Okay.
Daran benutzt ihr sie, Ötrox 75 Mikrogramm und ihre Gruppe, die sind ja klein geworden.
Ja, die Stromer ist in der Größe rückläufig.
Ja.
Sie sei zustand nach Appendectomy mit elf Jahren und zustand nach Tibia Fraktur links mit Osteoplatin behandelt wurde.
Ja, wann war diese Tibia Fraktur?
Vor zwölf Jahren.
Genau, sehr gut.
Sie haben keine Allergie und ich habe schon gesagt, Fleisch, wenn Sie zu viel Fleisch gegessen.
Nehmt die Patientin sonst noch Medikamente ein?
Medikamente ein...
Ach, wie ein Salb-Tomol-Ötrox.
Die Patientin nimmt noch die Pille?
Ja, natürlich.
Die Pille.
Wie lange die Pille?
Einige Jahre.
Okay.
Ja, gibt es Auffälligkeiten?
Ich sage es jetzt bewusst, dass es gemeinert ist, in der Familienvorgeschichte.
Ja, Ihre Mutter hat auch zweimal bei wenigen Trombosen erlitten.
Das ist aber auch die familiäre Neurodermitis, Asma.
Sie ist gleich Ihre Mutter.
Ja, okay.
Also, in der Familienanamnese besteht eine eindeutige Belastung an Asma Bronchale.
Asma Bronchale?
Ja, bei den Brüdern auch.
Bei der Mutter zweimal die Zustand nach tiefer, wohl tiefer Beinwähnentrombose.
Ja, bei der Vater aber Arturilli Hepartoni und Chypsuvae Diabetes Melitus.
Okay, gut.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Ja, Lungenarterielle Embolli.
Ja, es besteht der hochgradige Verdacht auf eine arterielle Lungenembolli.
Was spricht dafür?
Ja, plötzlich angefangen, Inspiratordiszipline und bisschen Vertigo.
Auch Reizfusten, auch vor einem Woche,
eine Knokunverletzung, wie die Trombose kommt und die RTL.
Das kann die Ursache sein, ja.
Es gab vor einer Woche eigentlich ein Bagatell-Trauma.
Es war ja nicht unbedingt eine ganz schwere Verletzung,
aber es gab ein Trauma in die Subminationstrauma Distortion des Sprunggelenkes
mit Hematom und Schwellung, Linker, Unterschenkel, Distall.
Eventuell kann sich dort eine Venentombose gebildet haben
und die jetzt nach dieser Zeit symptomatisch wird.
Und für die Lungenembolli spricht dieser plötzlich auftretende, fast Vernichtungsschmerz.
Die Leute haben ja ganz plötzlich Luftnoten um dieser Schmerz.
Es kommt zur Tachikadie oft, diese ganzen Geschichten.
Ja, was könnte differenzial diagnostisch in Betracht kommen?
Ja, Art und Dissektion, Akute Coronasyndrom, Ulcus ventriculi.
Sie trinken nicht so viel Alkohol, kann man auf Akute von Kratis nicht so viel.
Ja, also aufgrund dieses relativ geringen Alkoholkonsum
würde ich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt denken.
Aber akutes Coronasyndrom kann Rolle spielen.
Hinterwandinfarkt, in Fakt.
Ja, Hinterwandinfarkt, aber sicherlich ist in erster Linie die Verdacht
auf akute Lungenembolli ist da.
Gut, danke. Das haben Sie gut gemacht.
Sie haben rechtzeitig aufgrund auch der Beschwerden interveniert,
mit der, dass Sie gesagt haben, jetzt erst mal einen venösen Zugang legen,
eine die ersten Vitalparameter gemessen.
Um zu schauen, ist die Patientin Atem sufficent oder insuffizient eventuell.
Was macht der Blutdruck?
Der SBO2, Sie haben sogar die Blutgase gemacht, Sie haben eine EKG abgeleitet.
Damit haben Sie erst mal, denke ich, das optimal gemacht.
Sie haben Blut abgenommen für die Meere, für Troponintest, diese ganzen Geschichten.
Sie haben der Patientin Sauerstoff gegeben.
Die Patientin hat das als wohltuend empfunden und es hat,
glaube ich, die Patientin auch beruhigt, weil sie haben gleich gehandelt.
Sie haben nicht nur gefragt, sondern sie haben auch etwas unternommen.
Das ist richtig oft für Patienten, gerade wenn sie so eine Situation haben.
Die Patientin hat schon diesen Vernichtungsschmerz und die Luftnot.
Das ist, denke ich, für die Patienten ein großer Stress.
Und da, denke ich, haben sie sehr gut reagiert und haben aber dann weiter befracht,
die Anamnese erfragt, sie haben nach einem Trauma gefragt, als Auslöser.
Hätten sie nicht danach gefragt, hätte die Patientin das nicht von selber gesagt.
Sie denkt da nicht dran, dass das damit tun haben kann.
Offenkundig kann es sich bei der Familie, das ist vielleicht noch nicht entdeckt worden,
um eine Blutgerinnungsstörung handeln.
Erbedingt gibt es mehrere Faktor 5, 7 und was auch immer.
Problematiken, die sind bisher noch nicht entdeckt worden,
obwohl die Mutter zwei tiefe Beinwedenturmbosen hatte.
Da sollte man eigentlich inzwischen so weit auch sein,
dass man das diagnostisch abklärt und dementsprechend die Familie berät.
Ist in diesem Falle nicht passiert, es kommt immer wieder vor.
Also wir haben die familiäre Asthma-Belastung,
die jetzt, was die Atelier Lungenembolie angeht,
wohl nichts damit zu tun hat, aber wahrscheinlich geht es um eine
Grinnungsstörung, die in der Familie sitzt.
Mütterlicherseits muss man so annehmen.
Gut, ja, vielen Dank.
Das haben Sie gut gemacht.
Und wann machen Sie jetzt Ihre Prüfung?
Ja, am Anfang Juli.
Okay, gut.
Aber ich habe nicht gefragt, wie Sie hierher gekommen sind,
weil vor zwei Stunden.
Ja, das können Sie natürlich fragen.
Die Patientin ist in Begleitung ihres Mannes gekommen.
Die Patientin ruft nicht den Krankenwagen an.
Die behandelt auch diese Distortion selbst.
Sie geht nicht so schnell gerne zum Arzt.
Sie will autonom sein.
Manchmal ist es gut und manchmal ist es gefährlich.
Gut.
Aber es ist eine gute Fall.
Interessant.
Aber Sie haben sich dem Fall gut angenehren.
Und es geht ja nicht darum, dass Sie eine ganz richtige Diagnose stellen,
aber Sie haben umsichtig gehandelt,
dass Sie gleich die Anamnese unterbrochen haben.
Und auch die in diesem Fall,
die erst mal die Akutversorgung eingeleitet haben.
Ja, sehr gut.
Gut, ich wünsche Ihnen dann noch für die Restwochen
eine entspannte Vorbereitung.
Sie wissen das alles und Sie können das.